This is an emergency
That man is trying to kill you
if you want to live.
You have to trust me.
What is going on?
I can see the future.
Let's try that again.
Those girls have no idea the power they can unlock.
I will kill them first.
Get down
Out of Web exclusively in movie theaters February 14th.
Welcome back everyone. It's Morbin' time.
Marvel and Sony have released a new Madame Web trailer
with some new footage and Spider-Man Easter Eggs.
So we'll break it all down.
I know there's a ton of questions about the timeline
here, where is this happening in the multiverse?
Because all of them in the trailer have Spider-Man
suits at some point, like their spider suits.
they all have Spider-Man symbols on them.
Unlike the Venom character.
You think the Venom would finally
have gotten his Spider-Man symbol at this point?
but that means that in this universe,
a version of Spider-Man would have had
to have been active already in the universe
to give them the idea in the first place to use
Spider-Man symbols like he's meant to come first.
Peter Parker. Then they come inspired by him.
Jerry seems pretty chaotic,
which is par for the course.
But we'll explain
what's going on. If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
as they say in the trailers.
The movie's coming out Valentine's Day weekend
basically pretty soon.
If you didn't think all the Morbius comparisons
were funny or you were making the Dakota
Johnson 50 Shades of Spider-Man connection here,
they actually released
probably what is the most spicy promo
I've ever seen a Spider-Man movie release
So while my character in the movie
may be able to see the future, I also can.
And I know what the future brings.
I know that when you see Madam Web,
you're going to love it.
In fact, I think you're going to see it twice.
they're really leaning into that whole 50 Shades
and Spider-Man with that.
Like obviously none of that energy
is coming off the actual trailers.
I don't think there's any of that
going on in the actual movie, but I love the way
they're kind of leaning into the jokes in the memes
here with the marketing.
like, do not shy away from the whole more?
Ben time of it all here.
Even Jared Leto sort of leaning into the Morbius
more Ben Time jokes.
I think that Sony kind of realized after all the more
Ben time stuff that happened the last couple of years
that people will enjoy these kind of Spider-Man
B movies.
and that's really the vibe of the movie.
It's kind of like a B movie with Spider-Man characters.
sense that you go to watch going into the movie
knowing that it's not going to be
on the level of, say, like Spider-Man,
no way home, something quite as polished as that.
But the movie is going to be a fun experience
nonetheless.
like there are a ton of movies out there
that just are not meant to be good movies,
like bad movies that are fun to watch, like the Room.
But I don't see that
Madame Web is going to be quite that crazy.
Like, it's not going to be like the room.
but you really need to temper your expectations
about what it is you're going to see.
Like, do not go into this movie
expecting something on the level of Spider-Man.
No way home.
all the test screenings have reportedly gone
well which means that people are having fun
like they're enjoying watching the movie.
It doesn't mean
the movie is going to win a ton of awards.
It just means people are having fun watching it.
So remember that when you go to see it generally,
the movie seems like it's going to be
a Terminator movie, like a Terminator plot inside
the Spider-Man universe or a Spider-Man universe.
Technically, this would be the Venom universe,
because all those Spider-Man spin off movies
Sony has been making are meant to be on the same earth
that we saw in the Venom movies.
The Morbius Post-Credits scene.
really good example.
This also this year they're releasing the Kraven movie
with Aaron Taylor-Johnson
cannot wait for the means to come out of that.
It's kraven time,
but you have the whole quicksilver of it all
that will also take place in the same universe
as the Venom movies,
as this massive web movie,
as the morbius post-credits scene.
Not exactly sure where in the timeline
kraven is going to fall relative to Madame Web
because Madame Web seems like most of it
takes place in the early 2000 and inside the MCU,
looking at present day like the Venom Universe,
for instance, we're into like 2025, 20, 26.
a lot of these movies seem like their origin stories.
For example,
they take place much earlier in the timeline.
Mata web, obviously an origin story for that character
with her slowly coming into her powers
from the comics, becoming more like comic book
Madame Web,
just a much younger version of the character
Fun Easter Egg, too.
In real life, if you didn't watch any of the Spider-Man
animated series episodes, they're fantastic.
I would recommend watching it,
because a lot of the stuff
that's happening in the modern movies,
Marvel movies, Sony, Spider-Man movies,
they're actually doing stuff that they already did
in Spider-Man, the animated series.
really good example
that Madame Web had huge arcs across that show.
One of the big ones was Secret Wars.
there was even an episode where Spider-Man travels
to a universe where he actually meets Stan Lee
at the Marvel offices in real life and learns
that he's a fictional character that Stan Lee created
end to boot.
Madame Web on that TV
show was played by Stan Lee's wife, Joan, in real life.
He even remarked on it during that episode
where Spider-Man meets Stan Lee as his creator.
I'm like, Wait a minute, I'm fictional. You created me.
love, the jokes there, too.
Like that was a wonderful lady. Who was that person?
that was your wife in real life.
this is what Dakota Johnson's version of the Madame Web
suit from the comics is meant to look like.
It's based on the original suit from the comics.
But you can see they change the Spider-Man symbol
a little bit.
I think this is mostly because they've tuned everything
up to modernize some stuff
and because they changed everyone's stories
from the comics like Madame Web, all the other Spider
Woman characters, all slightly different backstories,
even the Venom character,
for instance, two very different backstory
than he had in the comics.
what it looks like is happening
from all the trailers here is that Madame Web starts
out in the early 2000s
based on some of the markings on everything.
She's a normal medic
working at the hospital in New York City.
Her coworker here, played by Adam Scott, is actually
supposed to be a version of a young Uncle Ben.
He's married to a young Aunt Mae.
end, I think this is when Peter Parker's mother,
Mary Parker, is pregnant with him.
Emma Roberts is supposed to be in the movie playing
Peter Parker's mother.
Notice in the footage,
she's super pregnant, like tiny baby Peter Parker
about to be born the main villain
we see throughout the timeline in the trailers.
Here is Ezekiel Sims from the comics.
it seems like he's come back in time Terminator style
to kill all these women
before they become versions of Spider Woman
In a young Peter Parker.
Before he can become a Spider-Man
all these scenes of them in their spider-woman suits,
using their powers, fighting the older version of him
with the white hair, obviously
meant to be flash forwards to later in the timeline,
setting up their backstory, explaining
why he wants to time travel to the past
to prevent this from ever happening.
all this new footage they just released
gives us a little bit more of the storyline.
It's a little bit clear,
but I think he just supports a lot of the theories
about what's going on with this whole Terminator plot
and the time travel At some point in the past,
Madame Web's powers start to manifest.
She starts having visions of the future,
the way they're portraying her abilities.
Now, I think she can see potential futures
the way that Doctor Strange did when he was using
the Time Stone in Avengers Infinity
War to keep all their possible futures with Thanos.
Like during the trailers, you see fights go down
that she says, Let's try that again.
She's probably seeing a potential future,
not the actual future.
She keeps having visions of Ezekiel
coming to kill them here in the past.
At some point, she starts to track down
all the different girls to keep them safe.
All while having these encounters
with Ezekiel through the past.
in, it seems like the way they're presenting
all this footage during the main part of the movie,
when it's in the early 2000s, these younger
versions of the characters don't totally know
what's going on or why is Eagles trying to kill them
merely theory right now?
And this is a big trope of a lot of movies like this
is that they'll probably have Ezekiel do an evil
villain monologue where he tells them all
why he's trying to kill them,
and that's how they learn that they're eventually
going to get powers and become these versions of Spider
Woman, like he'll tell Madame Web that she's meant
to be this crucial figure in the multiverse
in the future, as her powers grow
and she starts turning more into comic book Madame Web.
now, the comic book
version of Madame Web is a little bit different.
Like she has the special floaty chair
that she flies around and she can actually open portals
across the multiverse.
in at least right now, at this point in the timeline.
Dakota Johnson's
Madame Web doesn't seem like she can do that yet.
they may have just tuned her powers down for the
purposes of this movie, like powered her a little bit.
Or it might just be that
she hasn't become that powerful yet.
And eventually she will really easy way
to explain how she connects a lot of these characters
with Tom Holland's Spider-Man
and everything happening in Secret
Wars is they are going to cameo at any point
during Secret wars.
Not really sure about that yet,
the other versions of Spider Woman that they have
in all the trailers here are Sydney Sweeney.
Everybody recognizes who is playing Julia Carpenter.
Her suit looks pretty close to the comic book
version of her suit
is generally true of all the other characters you like,
they're pretty close to their comic book suits
in the comics.
She got her Spider-Man powers during an experiment
where she was injected with a special spider
venom concoction.
she eventually took the title of Madame Web.
And Cassandra Web kind of bestows her powers on her.
But I don't think they'll totally get into that plot
during this movie.
as you can see from the trailers,
she basically has the same powers of Spider-Man,
but she can also create psionic webbing,
which is what you're seeing her do in the trailers.
Celeste O'Connor You also probably recognize
in the trailers here is playing Mattie Franklin
from the comics she's actually meant to be.
Jonah Jameson's niece in the comics.
I don't know they're going to do that inside this Venom
universe, though, one of the funny things
they started doing in all the Tom Holland's
Spider-Man movies is basically explaining that J.K.
Simmons is every single version of Jonah Jameson
in every single universe.
he was also just in Spider-Man across the spider-verse
as the other versions of Jonah Jameson.
Her backstory is a little bit crazier, though.
Like her father was meant to be part of a secret group
with Norman Osborn, Cassandra Webb,
who all performed a ritual to give them random,
mystical powers so that everyone got different powers.
Cassandra Webb gained immortality.
Mattie took her father's place in the ritual and got
pretty much the same type of powers as Spider-Man.
I don't think they're going to get too crazy
with the whole mystical side of Spider-Man's powers
are like the Spider-Man totems, just because that was a
big part of the Ezekiel storyline in the comics.
I'm really just expecting them
to just simplify all that stuff
for the purposes of this movie
and what's happening inside this Venom universe.
so like all the storyline with the inheritors,
all that crazy stuff.
Not really expecting them to go there in Isabella
murphy said,
you also probably recognize
this playing on your corazon from the comics.
generally my expectation for this movie
is that they will wind up defeating
Ezekiel in the past and they will eventually become
versions of Spider Woman.
But because of everything that's happening with
the time travel, the timeline will have been changed.
So something will change about the future
for this universe's version of Peter Parker.
Spider-Man they'll probably be some moment
at the end of this movie,
maybe like a post-credits scene that helps it connect
with the other Sony spin off movies like the Venom
movie, like the Morbius Post-Credits scene,
where we get a slightly better explanation
of how these characters will crossover
with those other Sony Spider-Man characters?
Real big reminder, though,
this movie is happening in the early
2000, mostly so way earlier in the timeline.
So would have to be like some sort of flash forward
at the end of the movie.
If they're going to do that.
like Dakota Johnson's
Madame Web would have to show up talking
to a version of Tom Hardy's
Venom or Morbius or somebody from one of those movies.
maybe because the Kraven movie is also coming out later
this year, it'll be a kraven
kind of post-credits scene because that movie also
seems like it takes place earlier in the timeline.
Generally, though, this is all meant to be based
on that Morbius Post-Credits scene.
Sony is trying to set up their own spinoff Sinister
Six franchise of movies
like a Sinister Six movie with a brand new version
of the team set in that universe,
the real question, though, is who's going to be
the main version of Spider-Man in that universe?
for those.
Are you asking about Spider-Man four?
We probably won't hear too much about that
for a couple more months.
I think Marvel is just waiting because there's
so much other stuff that they're working on right now.
In The big thing this year for them is Deadpool 3.
So we'll probably get that first Deadpool
3 trailer at the Super Bowl.
then after Deadpool 3 comes out,
then we'll start hearing more about Spider-Man 4.
I literally just posted that.
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool
3 Teaser trailer click here to watch that
and click here to learn
what's going on with Spider-Man four right now.
Thank you so much for watching.
and I'll see you guys in the next one1